you can get hacked by a QR code hackers
use them to steal your private
information and your money it's called
quing short for QR fishing how does it
work attackers create fake QR codes and
send them via email or messenger they
can even print the QR code on a sticker
and stick it on Street advertising
scanning such a code takes the victim to
fake login Pages or payment forms that
closely resemble legitimate websites
unwitting victims may enter their
usernames passwords or other
confidential details into these
malicious forms and pass this
information on to the attackers the
problem is that most browsers on mobile
devices don't display the full address
bar so it's not easy to spot a fake
website the FBI warns that quing is very
dangerous and that goes for everyone be
safe